[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right guess of course is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show now so far many challengers
we've had like a hundred and something
challengers no winners absolutely no
winners no one has caught us making
mistakes because yeah because we're
perfect exactly perfect in every way
well tonight a fan named Megan Seneca
thinks she caught a mistake she says it
happened during my recent interview with
Jennifer Aniston High Conan you had an
interview with Jennifer Aniston and you
were discussing how her facial routine
how she keeps her face looking so nice
and in the process of her explaining she
was looking at your face and she noticed
this blood vessel underneath your eye
well I think that's a VI can't remove
that because that supplies oxygenated
blood to my brain veins don't carry
oxygenated blood veins carry
deoxygenated blood from your extremities
back to your heart arteries carry
oxygenated blood so I'm really looking
forward to how you're going to prove me
wrong on this one
I'm kind of looking forward to seeing
how you're gonna prove well guess what
all right Megan's wrong Oh dead wrong
yes she is she is dead wrong
you see Megan you say that veins don't
carry oxygenated blood well that would
be true of most people but it's not true
of me take a look at this very rare
video from my childhood
well this child is a medical miracle his
arteries and veins both carry oxygenated
blood to his brain he's headed for
greatness probably somewhere on basic
cable television
when I said video I think what I'd meant
to say was super 8 right sure
because I did not video that and they
didn't have video but they didn't have
doctors that knew about basic cable
[Laughter]
I don't want to hear any fan Corrections
about this fan correction we're all
gonna move on from here yeah we're gonna
move on anyway the challenge still
stands if you think you've spotted an
error on our show reported team koco.com
slash ha ha I found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro we'll take
a break